sein coming out war alles andere als
einfach die leute jung spricht darüber
jetzt sehr offen in seiner neuen
biografie egal was andere sagen und
jetzt auch in bild denn mir nun live
zugeschaltet ist der schlagerstar jong
sie schreiben in ihrem buch unter
anderem dass ihr vater nach ihrem
coming-out rund einem jahr nicht mehr
mit ihnen gesprochen hat konnten sie ihm
diese reaktion bis jetzt verzeihen
mittlerweile ist schon ich glaube es ist
niemals gut niemals positiv um in hass
zb jetzt auch noch zu leben also ich
glaube mein vater hat mich geliebt er
musste nun ich mir das zeigen kommen und
deshalb bin ich jetzt auch so wichtig
nicht meine regeln und familien
vielleicht manche menschen am beispiel
zu sein
oder manche väter oder mütter die die
augen zu öffnen das ist eigentlich
völlig okay ist uns ja aber mir hat es
lange gebraucht jetzt ist alles super
wenig sozial happy aber man braucht das
als kleines in braucht man wirklich die
bestätigung von pablo mama das ist okay
so sagen mir du bist ja sagen natürlich
auch die zeit in der beute konnten
direkt mit der sie berühmt geworden sind
war keine einfache sie hatten das gefühl
sie müssten sich verstellen
würden sie heute mit einem was sie jetzt
wissen sich nochmal das entscheiden in
einer boyband mitzumachen
ich habe mit kurzen jacken traum gelebt
wirklich weil ich bin ja ein cowboy oder
vorjahr werden auch das war ein traum
aber ja leider hat sich ein management
die die zum beispiel das buch erzähle
einmal gesagt sollte ich bin frau da
sind meint benz keine schule jungen sind
aus um das natürlich mit zu tragen als
junger mensch wenn er es wirklich weiß
ist alles vorbei das gefühl hat sich
auch bald war die fans wenn die wirklich
wissen was wir nicht leben dann ist es
nicht gut und das ist natürlich zusammen
negativ deshalb mittlerweile um
um solo erfolgreich zu sagen die bühne
zu stellen aber ab dass alle menschen
wissen dass ich mit ihm zusammen labour
hatte samstag geburtstag
wir hatten über 3.500 likes das ist für
mich so eine bestellte gucken das ist
akzeptiert ist und ja das ist so toll
dass jetzt auch noch mal zu überleben
glauben sie denn mittlerweile hat sich
so viel in unserer gesellschaft geändert
dass jetzt ein schwules mitglied einer
boyband kein problem mehr wäre denn wenn
der mund mitglied selber so weit ist um
das zu zeigen ich würde damals wurde ich
vom eingang außen zeitung in england
eigentlich die hat sie die geschichte
überstiegen und mich mein damaliger der
saga von goisern auch und dann haben wir
unsere geschichte endlich selber gegeben
weil wir uns nicht länger unterdrückt
fühlen auch sei aber dass menschen
manchmal vergessen dass das jeder mensch
braucht sie verarbeiten erst zuerst
jahre zu machen ich bin im opti in die
schule meine fragen hat das nicht
akzeptiert aus ich war einfach auch
nicht soweit damals aber was wirklich
finde ich komme jetzt nur sagen freiheit
in das verdienen die autofreie zu lieben
und es ist alles alles wird gut sein
aber für dich niemals gezwungen wegen
presse oder oder oder fans zu sagen denn
nur nicht so weit ist noch mal ich weiß
dass mein leben jetzt gesagt du bist
also endlich los sein kann
jetzt haben sie gesagt nicht wegen
kresse oder fans was raten sie den
menschen jungen mädchen jungen jungen
männern die das selbe geschlecht lieben
aber jetzt nicht unbedingt der
öffentlichkeit stehen aber was ist
trotzdem ihr rat an diese menschen die
jetzt vielleicht auch keine einfache
zeit am anfang haben mein buch egal was
andere sagen ich habe ein buch was ich
auch bis jetzt vom laser und leserinnen
dass es hoffnung gibt und das hoch wie
ich als ich ein kleiner jungen in
holland war nach sieben oder acht
ich wusste ich bin anders aber ich hatte
kein beispiel kein positiver beispiele
mit nämlich nicht vergleichen kommt wenn
meine geschichte was ich immer buch
erzähler oder jetzt auch wieder mit euch
oder in andere interviews gesagt es ist
einfach aufgeben ich ein kleines
beispiel sein kann
der junge und das mädchen irgendwo
zu sagen papa mama guck mal mama du
kannst noch immer werden war der ila hat
auch hat auch eine tochter mit seinem
vater er ist auch seit 13 jahren
glücklich gute beispiele das ist mir
alles im leben das brauchen wir um
dieses gut sein und sicherlich ein gutes
beispiel das sind sie bestimmt ein
vorbild vielen dank die leute jungen das
sehen sich jetzt noch mal die zeit
genommen haben
dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren